alors jean bibi qui nous dit dernière
partie tome 3 minimum technique se fera
au fera avec ce qu'on a on travaille ce
qu'on a je vous promets pas je vous
promets pas un top 3 et c'est sûr et
j'en oublie aussi qui évoque quoi que
trois ça lui fait penser un peu
effectivement côté nerveux de courage et
en étant un ancien joueur de quake 3
jeux je suis assez d'accord on retrouve
un peu des sensations similaires même si
effectivement la sélection d un
environnement beaucoup plus ouvert oui
alors moi c'est un jeu qui me rappelle
kim ho qui en appelle à l'eau en fait
bizarrement alors c'est je peux suivre
les devants et le forcer à l'islamisme
alors c'est un vieux jeu et des spots et
futuriste et pas beaucoup de voix déjà
postulé comme si borderlands un peu on
en a parlé aussi le
le pen qui est maintenant des
personnages
watch même si on le rappelle les
personnages ou pas
normal non pas de différence
aussi vite
pas autant dit
je voulais prendre globe and mail a
effectivement la promenade avant moi l'a
pris donc moi je ne pourrais pas le
prendre
bowden c'est le tracker est ce assez il
est assez bien à jouer parce que il
détecte les ennemis en fait je vois les
traces des années et si on commençait
avec un personnage je vous conseille
donc soit depuis que j'ai la klein soit
blood and ce qu'il ya un personnage
fourbe
si on a du mal à voir les ennemis qui
est un personnage assez pratique alors
on va essayer de retrouver ce petit
vaisseau mais je ne le vois toujours pas
à il a alors et alors là c'est toujours
pas moi qui saute
tu a suggéré qu'on doit la balle orange
est suggérée et on y va et on y va et on
y va et on y va et on va tenter d'y
aller on va tenter de survivre créatures
way we dance et là ça va alors je crois
que l'un de nos coéquipiers a décidé que
c'était trop risqué qui part thiey qui
partait
barça
et c'est un peu raté j'étais pas très
bien couvert
je pense que le top 3 c'est pas pour
tout de suite
alors le jeu par contre c'est que la cie
la zone qui avec moi me réanime je vais
tomber du vaisseau non alors j'ai pas si
c'est un bon copain effectivement sur le
vaisseau alors j'aimerais bien vous
montrer voilà il va me soigner et
ensuite on commence à trouver dans le
vide je pense je pense qu'il s'agit là
d'un bug mais voilà c'est pas fini comme
le dit je suis ambitieux on va essayer
sur les je me retrouve avec une
d'émotion c'est une arme complètement
pas mal et un trip qui est aussi un
style assez sympa est ce que vous êtes
tous les trois on est tous les trois on
a décidé de tous partir parce que
j'avais perdu gt gt mort posé mon trip
c'est un trip alors par contre je pense
alors je sais pas si c'est le beau jeu
si le terrain c'est le mot c'est le beau
je voyais alors je suis même pas certain
soit le bush alors on dirait que je me
sens
mam est ainsi de parler parler parler
parler les murs alors c'est un kit
phoenix qui va me permettre de ramener
tout le bouclier et matous de ma vie on
a un coût
en fait les violettes parce que j'ai
généralement je vais alors j'ai un
collègue qui s'est fait tuer on veut
sauver parce que m'a quand même sauver
l'être tout à l'heure c'était fini non
là on est petit mais il doit être
quelque part par la lie en dessous j'ai
raté mon dieu pendant deux ans voire est
en fait alors nous montre un truc sympa
on aura fait un an qu'il annonce et un
hologramme
alors cet émirat
voilà un joli alors vous l'avez pas
présenté alors je l'avais rarement vu
ses mirages c'est un personnage qui est
capable de faire des les hologrammes
c'est à dire en fait ils se cachent en
fait projette une image projette une
image de lui voilà la géniale je sais
pas si j'ai pas essayé de passer la
longueur je sais juste de me planquer
alors ce qui est bien c'est de mettre un
aimant pouvons vous dire où sont les
ennemis lâché en train de montrer à mon
collègue genou et demi j'ai trouvé ça
très ils sont plusieurs personnes
on a été éliminés malheureusement on
n'aura pas fait top 3 je suis vraiment
désolé gendarmes rangent et
effectivement c'est un réflexe que j'ai
pas encore totalement je vous rappelle
que le jeu sortirait semaine encore tous
les tous les réflexes effectivement jean
bibi c'est un leurre là le personnage
qu'on a vu avancer son passif en fait il
peut se poser là mais c'est assez sympa
parce qu'on croit qu'on va tuer
quelqu'un est en fait on ne tue pas du
tout envie de faire coucou astro furtif
en pathétique
ravary qu'à faire dire que c'est à dire
que j'ai fait un fragment sur cette
partie ce qui est quand même pas mal oui
à stocker les armes oui mais c'est ce
que j'avais dit les effets que je disais
j'ai plongé pas engorger touch 3g pas
encore j'ai pas encore l'habitude je ne
veux plus si je les six gelés à signer
ou pas qui vivait il va inventer
ailleurs voilà passé ce qui s'est passé
avec et ben en tout cas merci à tous
d'avoir suivi ce live
oui effectivement j'ai pas pour conclure
qu est ce que tu en penses de jeu un bon
en tout cas il est gratuit vous pouvez
vous faire par vous même si vous avez
une console ou un pc assez costaud mais
de ce qu'on m'a dit alors effectivement
ça pas besoin d'être une machine de
guerre
et voilà vous pourrez tester votre
opinion en tout cas on vous l'a dit
c'est un jeu effectivement qui servit on
va sûrement en entendre parler dans les
prochains dans les prochaines semaines
voire les prochains mois
c'est un peu la relève de fortes night
c'est ça trop s'avancer alors en corse
et sur la raison et alors ce qui est
assez marrant c'est que forte à vraiment
baisser depuis l'arrivée d'alex quand
même ça c'est vu il ya bien sûr twitch
il ya un vrai transfert alors je vais
juste répondre à l'astro furtif nous
demander ce que vous avez déjà fait
étape à eybens même avec mon niveau j'ai
réussi à faire un très beau top 1 avec 4
frags en plus mais en fait en tournant
en fait c'est un peu la loterie parce
que quand on tombe avec une bonne équipe
c'est plus facile de faire des top mais
c'est quand même un beau message
d'espoir c'est un voilà c'est un beau
message d'espoir pour pour tous les
joueurs qui sont là
voilà donc quatre autres furtif qui
dézingue il devait pas être là au début
mais une vie on en a déjà parlé d'apex
10 millions de joueurs en trois jours
effectivement et 25 millions en une
semaine ce qui est assez ce qui est
assez énorme
quand même donc voila moi je sais un jeu
que je trouve très sympa aussi avec
quelques bémols toujours pareil le pay
to skins
voilà je suis pas hyper fan de genre de
choses et je suis pas non plus hyper fan
du fake it ou oblige on est obligé
d'installer origines pour pouvoir jouer
au jeu et ça nous fait encore une
plateforme supplémentaire
c'est le seul bémol mais sinon dans le
jeu le jeu est assez sympa en tout cas